all right here we go
God Queen tyreme comin in July from the
HBC we're streaming you're screamin
Admiral barbarian to get into the great
so far so good
we're gonna go check out the Hilton of
the vaults we're totally not brainwashed
seemed like
all right I was gonna try and find some
boat weapons I got a shotgun that's
psycho their inventory Sarge did not
stop and pick up pretty much every gun
you see on the grounds I'm probably
gonna regret picking up a sniper rifle
but let's do this no regrets all right
get in there all right first impression
area the guns they feel I feel like they
have a lot more hat knock-back
definitely feels increase you're fine
right
less fine all right I'm gonna take a
second because I have not played
Borderlands 3 yet to just kind of look
at my inventory figure out what we got
so right now all we have is a Jacob
sniper rifle and a Jacob's shotgun okay
that is not my menu here's my menu all
right so we're playing his Mo's we're
playing through the first part of the
game don't really have a sense it of how
big everything is yet
we only got two weapons slots open
currently all right so we're still
pretty early on I think this is
something we saw got our first action
skill unlocked
oh that's funny if you look in the lower
right corner I'm using the controller
but there's actually her hand is in the
lower right corner on her own little
gamepad that is awesome
all right we're gonna skip tutorial
three folks out there we have the
ability to purchase an ability C railgun
that sounds cool grenade launcher
minigun let's go mini again I think iron
beer can have a number of things
unlocked oh I see you can do you can do
one per arm that's pretty cool alright
let's do this
that's a good turret
not so good I need where these guys drop
again cuz I got a little hasty on this
all right here we go with iron bear
iron bear come on slide
and hurry
I need another whip this is not a sniper
in here
smacked it down
thirty seconds
how interesting there's a
I probably don't want to jump off there
but I remember in Borderlands 2 you
could do a lot of exploration and they
were often things in places they expect
alright give me the bullets let's go
back and pick up a scan see if you pick
up another weapon real quick
yeah let's go to the mo
take care of that sir
and I think the thing I'm noticing right
away is the guns feel that they feel a
lot punch here the board lands to feel
like a lot of knocks back with your
being their shotguns of course that
could be a Jacob's thing just like we
got bareback I'm trying to resist
opening everything it's so hard to do in
this game all right
rapture upon us holy is the mouth that
bleeds you got all right here we go we
gotta go we gotta green again okay what
is this a Mallee one
that's how do I get to my gun menu
inventory there yeah okay we do not want
our tutorial
but I'm glad they have one all right so
Hyperion that's cool okay so Hyperion
guns have the shields that's pretty cool
and then what's our grenade doing it's
kind of bouncing around shooting
explosives
that's pretty rad and it looks like in
our side inventory we have a lot off and
at Jacobs I don't want to go find some
Cove weapons those are the themed ones
if I recall right along with some new
let's plays signing up for now don't
forget to like follow and obey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
Hyperion's shotgun
say hello to my little friend
we knew our doctors yeah
Oh
my bouncing friend
rack it up on there so far on our goal
to all billion guns I think we're only a
part way there I somehow feel like we're
not gonna reach a billion guns on this
street
alright moving forward we are not gonna
be fighting some sick beats shred that
soldier
[Music]
[Music]
these heretics
get down
Hyperion a liability my favorite sound
come back
yeah we still got more in your name do
it
shotguns are still gated I don't
remember shotguns feeling this good in
Borderlands ooh gonna break
all right children of the vault yeah it
seems kind of go the-- totally normal
for this world
you know for a cult they do some pretty
nice stained glass not gonna lie
let's move forward into their sweet beat
lair it's gonna look for more guns here
we're gonna try and get there as many
guns as possible I think right now we're
rolling Hyperion makeups I don't want to
go look for maybe some of the beam
weapons like The Cove
maybe don't turn the speaker's up to
death
drop down there
spend skillpoints seems like a good idea
so adds a Mantor to the back of iron
bear we don't have your friends with us
right now but iron bear is actually one
of the only people I'm aware of in
Borderlands who somebody can actually
ride you into combat which is kind of
awesome passive ability get stacking
bonuses with magazine size and
occasionally shots will deal fire damage
let's go with fire damage right now I
would love to have somebody ride with us
but we don't have a co-op partner right
now but I'm gonna bite out of gonna buy
it on principle that's what we do
alright so
[Music]
and we're gonna keep pushing forward
candles
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought I'd finish out you will dance
go die how it dry this is a guy when you
beat him to get his really good music
saga and there wasn't we're gonna want
to play it right now you're good
yeah
iron bear
[Applause]
[Music]
get there man the guns feel so good
[Applause]
[Music]
ketta don't want this bus isn't having
to get second
so though
[Music]
now we're not gonna give up
back here
[Applause]
somebody ready iron beer right now
[Music]
all right getting down to it
[Music]
okay all right there
alright guys we beat the game that's the
end of the game the game's over
alright that first section was pretty
intense just really quick
once I can guess should we is there
another section where you get to okay
all right we can play through that again
is another character actually so now
that we've already seen Moe's let's see
we got a bit of time I think we were
good so let's take a look at another
character see play all right so we can
play I think we streamed last time so we
streamed a Zane and we streamed Azamara
I haven't got to try other one though
let's go with really curious but I'm
Mara because she's one of the one of the
six sirens in the universe and we think
maybe the or like the plot will probably
revolve around the siren since they've
been such a central part of this series
and I'm gonna start by inverting my
controls again we also had a chance to
play with different weapons give me just
one second
inverts
I blame growing up Floyd sins
okay that's close to get into the great
vault got some new converts today guess
what they brought us the secret
if that doesn't earn them a special
place in the family I don't know what
does but first I want to get real for a
sec you've all accepted me even though I
wasn't for and abandoned my first words
weren't blood feud or ribcage
alright this time around we're playing
Azamara and actually also tell them to
curb weapon so I think the probe weapons
will run if that don't run out of ammo
they've just overheat
[Music]
she's a siren character she taught you a
bunch of different things I think one of
them is a ground down go check out her
skillet read a sec
you seem like a Cobra GOP weapons seem
like really useful weapons that around
see a TDR weapon
these new things when you reload today
we're gonna try to reload people
together this one's a homie rocker when
you reveal that it it's better when
you're not treating it
I don't even want to see you guys on the
reload
never thought I'd say this but that
reload is really good
just like it's like fireworks every time
you reload all right let me check my
skill tree really quick see we can do
maybe get our ground pound skip tutorial
all right what do you got
we got phase casts astral projection
that deals damage ground pounds and a
giant burning fist that locks enemies in
place that that sounds a little bit more
like Borderlands 2 why don't we go with
I'm really curious about her astral
projection let's go into this tree right
now so stack of rush helps reload and
switch elemental effects all right let's
go with this give this a try so we're
gonna ask her project
after we deal with this turret
we're trying to find different routes
seem to be a spin up on this to you
getting close
if you just shout if she's a witch I
guess there's some slightly different
dialogue depending on who you are
temptation to always be reloading in so
high ok these do you run out of ammo
sorry this is the one
explore over here a little bit
I remembered it you know like in
Borderlands 2 there were a lot of times
where I would be alleging my way out to
places thinking you know they didn't
expect me to go there and all of a
sudden there would be a crate there a
lot of the places you would jump to
turns out they were intentional all
right
[Music]
I'm addressing as a ground pound all
right
through the first section open up the
toilet and find us some you guns all
right you got a blood-soaked repeater
and has to underbarrel grenade through
flat also flat up as under barrel
attachments I'm curious about this one
your barrel attachments how do you fire
your underbarrel that's right oh okay
there's AA dad on the d-pad so we now
have an underbarrel grenade launcher
does this one have a secondary nope okay
we got an undergrad Renee lockers and
I've also just noticed you can spot
things we're friends alright so we're
gonna get the underbarrel grenade
launcher ago or we could just sit here
and admire the view
see we've got a technical issue but
don't worry we'll post the welcome bid
later along with some new let's plays
signing up for now don't forget to like
follow and obey
[Music]
alright see this under real grenade
launchers
but definitely feeling a little bit less
tanky this time around
well that depends on your bills
I mean I could shoot him or barrel
I'm never gonna not reload I'm just
always gonna reload I can't help it all
right doll weapon swaps between
three-shot bursts in semi-auto
[Music]
yeah why not so semi-auto reshot burst
Oh sound design is all right great
alright five shot burst that seems
better this is for shot burst this
weapon bounces on impact and this one it
has a second barrel that increases fire
rate by 25%
yeah that's good bounces on impact it
seems more fun
they just really like that death metal
all right here we go
y'all deserve a better again this one is
mediocre crab totally automatic with the
knife on the end
we're gonna hold on to that one reload
and it does a homing missile attack
this grenades basically just turned into
landmines
reloading I got better reloading the not
reloading
we'll go back into this boss fight
do you get
does
my gut is just so much better when you
reload
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I see the holy Otto
there we go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe other skills everybody why even
try
to reload them to death
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rubbish reload our way through this boss
night
[Applause]
[Music]
all right clear down run - that was with
Amara I think we can do one more run is
Zane real quick cuz we can stream got
about 21 minutes in a stream so yeah we
already ran through as knows that was
Amara the siren and I think we can do is
a in the semi-retired bounty hunter now
let's see siren
I'm assuming it's the operative
and as usual I will have to invert the
controls apologies in advance
alright let's go one more round
Zayn
hang on let me just invert my controls
and this will be our last round through
this demo I just want to get through all
the available characters
okay [ __ ] it's control we're gonna
invert our controls
oh yeah Matt vertical Oh regular
vertical look okay here we go
all right good to go and you can
probably get into skills right away so
many choices
yes
all right so we can do digi clone that
seems interesting we can do I'm already
down as passive Street barrier we can do
sentinel drones or we can do digi clone
excuse it's just that no drones serious
about this one increased movement speed
up to killing an enemy weapon swap speed
or gun damage moving been damaged while
moving that sounds about right and what
are we got equips
we got a doll and a high period
[Music]
got green tyreme coming at you live from
the HBC
[Music]
good all right so we're gonna do this
last run-through as sane as you can play
here at e3 this is the third one
definitely not taking with him
suryun
vonabell town get other germs
a chance
- give his shields with just soaking up
some damage
give me your hair
yeah it's getting pretty good
turn back in five seconds
vanishing
that's where we get some visibility on
where they are
tell you
let's go check our usual toilet spot a
huge fan all right what do you got now
Jacobs critical hits and damaged -
projecting front-facing shield returns
bullets to your magazine oh that's
interesting
so the more you get hit the more bullets
you get back and we'll just do a full
swap out I think these were cool John
Luke was awesome stream last time I
think you got a gun like that
we've got a technical issue but don't
worry we'll post the welcome in later
along let's plays signing up for now
don't forget to like follow and obey
[Music]
more run through
firing hard hitting this gun I think it
says the more I get hit the more full I
get back in the magazine
[Music]
alright you got another gun chest back
here we'll go see what else we can pick
up ok greens this them all right what do
we got 600 appraoch it's yes yes please
second barrel the Greece's fire rates
unlimited baggies in size weapon heats
up and eventually breaks okay
and this one has ricochet bullets oh
cool we got a curved weapon all right
this one has zip rockets what is it
rockets come over here guys
yeah
yeah
I'll say so figure out where this
grenade actually does something it's a
teleport
and your barrel rockets on the pistol
all right here we go
moving it may be interesting NASA when
we got before all right
I guess they get all the weapons I've
tried that first action shotgun was
probably my favorite
crunching heart
[Applause]
little buddy
nice this melee seems to have a bit more
of a to it
get some gear on the way in all right
well shoot the serial bus you know play
some rad tunes mailbox yes please
see there's anything else here that we
haven't seen yet
all right what do we got damage the
front projecting face shield amplifies
weapon damage that seems useful and this
one ricochets bullets
let's go with four run facing the damage
think that'll come in handy boss and
then I think that'll be a first read one
more boss fight
there's totally ground down this game
trying to figure out of his melee does
more damage it looks like it
all right here we go boss fights
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean
this is good we actually want to take
damage
yeah damage output
they began to shoot at us
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
the big seeds abilities right now so
they're more complimentary than they do
something that's really helping my
damage output
[Music]
[Music]
nobody
all right well thank you guys so much
for joining us we were playing some
Borderlands 3 we made it through quite a
few the people we made through Mo's you
made it through tomorrow made it through
Zane we have yet to see flack spelled
with a for the the Beastmaster so I'm
not sure when we'll see that in the near
future but uh board waving series coming
up on September 13th so it'll probably
be sooner rather than later
Wow I'm Aaron Sampson Oh it'll be at
Gamescom I hear that we're gonna see
flack at Gamescom so we will be there
thank you so much everybody my name is
Aaron Sampson you've been watching our
stream from gamespot of Borderlands 3
we'll see you guys later bye